de loin il s'impose au regard il a su
résisté aux outrages du temps à la
guerre de cent ans et même à la
révolution c'est là des sept clochers
qui ornait l'abbatiale de déols en
gravit sont les 90 marches de l'édifice
du moyen-age on découvre un panorama à
couper le souffle
d'eole était situé sur le chemin de
saint jacques de compostelle
c'est cet âge d'or qui explique aussi la
candidature au classement mondial du
patrimoine de l'unesco ce qu'il faut
comprendre aujourd'hui c'est que un
classement unesco ça n'est pas qu'un
classement d'un patrimoine fusse-t-il
d'ailleurs le plus beau patrimoine il
faut aussi que ceux qui sont
propriétaires du patrimoine la
collectivité l'ensemble de la communauté
sont empare pour le faire vivre
l'expliqué le valoriser l'abbaye
bénédictine notre-dame de terol a été
fondée il ya plus de mille ans par m le
noble seigneur de déols des fêtes
médiévales sont organisés sur ce site
qui dispose d'un musée celui ci renferme
de nombreux vestiges
ici l'ancien et le moderne font bon
ménage grâce à la technologie l'idée de
ce dépôt de pré dossier c'est
effectivement s'il agit de déols pouvait
avoir la chance d'être retenue
patrimoine est reconnue patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco on aurait une
rayonnement et une mise en valeur de la
vie de des sommes très importantes qui
dépasserait les frontières du
département l'indre des retombées sur le
tourisme des retombées économiques
puisque le tourisme et est liée aussi à
l'économie et puis vraiment une mise en
valeur un patrimoine pour cette
présélection plus de 2000 sites
clunisiens sont en lice à travers
l'europe